من هنا تبدا استعداداتهم لعرض مميز في هذه
الساحه بمدينه كادوغلي في ولايه جنوب
كردفان حيث جاء المتصارعون من كل مناطق
جبال النبل لرسم صوره ترى كل مكونات هذا
المجتمع انها جزء منها المصارعه او كما
يسميها اهل المنطقه الصرع تراث قديم يعبر
عن القوه والشجاعه وعن التعدد القبائل
والعشائر المصارعه تحققت لنا
اهداف يمكن الولاده كانت متصارعه في
الذخيره فيها موت حسح حاليا الناس
شايفينهم بعينكم ذيل الناس مشتركين كلهم
هم الاثنين موجودين نوبه عرب موجودين هم
الاثنين حسب عليهم موجودين المصارعين في
الميدان لهم اهداف يرون ان هذا الارث
يحققها ويعبر عن طموحات انسان المنطقه
دور المراه حاضر بالتجيع والغناء والرقص
وبث الحماسه بين المتنافسين
المصارعه هنا في تعبر عن ارث وثقافه كبيره
جدا هم فرحين الان بعرض هذه الثقافه وهذا
التراث
يستمر التعبير عن الفرح بعرض تراث قديم
يتعلق بالرقص ويخصص لايام الزواج
بعد ما خلصت طبعا شهر
بعد ما الناس قرصوا لما نيجي زمان التراث
ده شهر 7 ده الناس بقى
النحاس اله ايقاعيه تطرق بطريقه معينه
ولمناسبات متعدده تستنفر هذه الاله الناس
لحدث معين يطرق الناس في وفاه احد ابناء
المد من الذكور بالتحديد
ويترك النهاد في المناسبات العامه
التي تخص الدوله التراث الشعبي في جبال
النوبه يعبر عن ثقافه عريقه ويسعى المجتمع
للمحافظه عليها وتحقيق السلام من خلالها
سالم الهاشمي العربي